how do I build a video streaming service
on Google Cloud here are your eight
steps to put together a video on demand
streaming service on Google Cloud first
you ingest a new video file into Google
Cloud Storage bucket Cloud functions
then detects that new file in the bucket
and initiates the transcoder job the
transcoder API transcodes the video
files into a desired output format
the resulting transcoded videos are then
placed into a separate cloud storage
bucket which serves as the origin
storage for the media CDN media CDN then
distributes these video files at the
edge closer to the user the user can
stream that newly ingested and
transcoded video files on any device
you would use cloud monitoring to
monitor those real-time metrics such as
your latency cache hits cache misses Etc
and then Cloud armor is used to filter
by IP and GEOS for places you really
don't want your service to be offered
alright that's how you build a video
streaming service on Google Cloud
[Music]